welcome to the rust in replied course
this course will introduce you to the
rust programming language with it in the
description there are links to various
materials used and mentioned in this
course
specifically
there is a one-click link to the
interactive course powered by replied
which allows you to learn rust
completely within your browser
there is also a link to the slides
mentioned which can be used as a cheat
sheet for us
finally there is a link to an article
written by yours truly which walks
through rust and the interactive
projects
this course assumes intermediate
knowledge in at least one other
programming language if you are new to
programming why not try the interactive
free codecamp curriculum
this is an interactive course going over
the basics of the rust programming
language within your browser
first you will get an overview of rust
the course covers the basics of rust but
you can also find some notes of this in
the linked slides or article
then you can follow the interactive
content to create your own cli
calculator
where you can perform basic arithmetic
operations through the command line
then you will create an image combiner
this project takes two images and
combines their pixels into one new image
first an overview of rust
a quote from the official rust book
rust deals with low level details of
memory management data representation
and concurrency the language is designed
to guide you naturally towards reliable
code that is efficient in terms of speed
and memory usage
the main tooling within the rust
ecosystem are
rust c which is the compiler that takes
your rast code and compiles it into a
binary which is machine readable code
rest up which is the command line
utility
to install and update rust and cargo the
rust build system and package manager
which you'll get a lot of experience
using throughout this course
and now moving on to the first project
the cli calculator
to begin i have a rebel bolt using the
nyx language in replit this allows me to
define the necessary tooling for the
project a link to this template is
available in the description of this
video if you want to code along
you can use cargo to create a new rust
project in the current working directory
by typing in cargo new followed by the
project name which we will call
calculator
this creates a new directory named
calculator initializes it as a git
repository
and adds useful boilerplate for your
project
the cargo.tml file
is the manifest used by cargo to manage
your project's metadata
this is similar to a package.json file
if you are familiar with those
the main.rs file is the default entry
point for your application
you can see it contains a function
declaration
using the fn keyword with the handle
main
as well as a call to the print line
macro which prints to the console in
rust a macro is denoted by the
exclamation mark character
which is also known as the baying symbol
to run the project
navigate into the calculator directory
then you can either use the cargo run
command
which will compile your code and then
run the compiled binary
as you can see hello world is printed
out
or you can use rust c
which is the compiler
where you pass in an argument
as the location to your entry point file
in our case this is the source folder
and the file is main.rs
this will compile your code
into a binary
and it will be placed within your
working directory
then you can run the binary
throughout this project i will just be
using cargo to run the project
so let's remove that file
the rust standard library comes with an
env module which allows access to the
command line arguments passed when
calling the program
the necessary exports from the env
module for this project are the args
function and the arg struct
the args function returns an instance of
the aux struct
and is imported into the file scope with
the following syntax use keyword
followed by standard
the module name env
the name of the function args and the
name of the struct args
to get an idea of what the aux struct
looks like
you can declare a new variable named
args
using the let keyword
and assign the value of the return of
calling the function args
then
use the print line macro to print the
value of the args variable
to do this place curly brackets within
the string as the first argument
and pass the variable you want to go
within the curly brackets
now if you run this code
you will see the following error
args cannot be formatted with the
default formatter because the trait
display is not implemented for args
that's a lot to take in
but for now this error comes about
because the print line macro does not
know how to format the argstruct however
you can just follow the compiler's
advice here to extend the formatter
using
the colon question mark syntax
now
running this code you should be able to
see the output
as you can see the arg struct is printed
to the console and it contains an inner
field
which consists of the location of the
compiled binary
you can confirm this
by running the application and passing
it an argument
free code camp
now we can see free codecap is in the
inner array
when we ran our code you might have
noticed
that the compiler threw a warning
saying we have an unused import
we don't strictly have to import args
but if you want to explicitly type the
aux variable
you can do so
using the aux struct that we imported
like so
now running the code that warning should
no longer be there
to access the arguments within the
argstruct
within the aux variable
you can use the nth method which exists
on the aux struct
first let's declare a new variable named
first
and assign it the value of calling the
nth method on args hovering over the nth
method
you can see the function definition
where it looks like it takes in two
arguments
however
being a method on a struct
the first argument is implicit
and is usually
a reference to self
where self is destruct
in this case this is a mutable reference
to self
the argument that needs to be passed in
is n which is a u size or a number
and it returns the nth element of the
iterator
which is wrapped in an option
let's unpack what all of that means
so accessing the first argument by
passing
0
is printed to the console
you'll notice you will still get an
error if you run the code
this area is saying that the augs
variable cannot be borrowed as mutable
we notice that in the definition
the nth method takes a mutable reference
to in this case args
so in order to use the method
we need to declare args as a mutable
variable
after doing that
we should be able to run the code
and this is what the first variable's
value is it is sum
wrapping the value we are interested in
sum is a variant on the option enum
this will become more clear as we define
enums later on for now
just know that you can unwrap options
to get the value inside rerunning this
code
we should see
that the value is no longer wrapped in
sum
however
in this case if we pass in an index
where there is no argument
rerunning the code
you will see that the application
panicked
panicking is rust way of erroring out
during run time
you can see thread main panicked at
called option unwrap on a non-value
this is because
when there is no value
to access using the end method none is
returned as opposed to sum with a value
so instead of unwrapping let's just
print that value
and first the
variable is none
and and
none has no value therefore it cannot be
unwrapped
to fix this
let's get the first argument out
and once again unwrap
now running our code
you will see that we get free code camp
we know we want our application to take
in three arguments
first being the first number
as well as an operator
being plus times divide or minus
and this will be the next argument
let's unwrap that
as well as a third argument being the
second number
to get an idea of all of these let's
print them out to the console
first operator and second
running this let's add some arguments
we would expect to use this application
by going one
plus two for example
however running this our application
panics
apparently we are still unwrapping on a
none value
well which of these is the non value
let's keep adding arguments to find out
that application still panics four
the application still panics
now we are passing six arguments into
the application and it is still
panicking
let's add more
finally the application doesn't panic
and this is because the nth method
returns an element
of an iterator
and we know it mutability iterates over
the args variable
internally what this means is
the nth method will look something like
this
where we have immutable reference to
self
as well as n which is
the u size or the index
and we know
this returns an option
where it is either a string of the value
we want
or none
now south we know is our obstruct
but what nth does
is for each n
we can assume n in this case as an
example
assume it equals
zero
so we are
accessing the first element
there is some sort of iterator over self
accessing let's say that inner array
and it is calling next on that array
as you can see
next advances the iterator and returns
the next value
so
in accessing the first element
when the end method is called a second
time
the iterator has passed the first
element
so that second call
or calling next again
will result in
the
second element being passed
let us look at it from this perspective
if at this point inner
is equal to an array
of
these two arguments
calling next brings up
the first argument
calling next again
would bring up the second argument
so
as we unwrapping here
and let's get rid of this
as we are unwrapping
the variable
into first
which in the case of our call would be 1
calling the nth method again on 2
this time starts at the plus argument
and 2 becomes
the first element after that
and then 3 is the second index of the
iterator
practically this means if we want to
access
the elements we are interested in
what we actually need to do when we are
calling just this code
and we don't want it to panic
we want the first next element
running this should yield what we want
now unlike some other languages you
cannot perform basic arithmetic
operations on
strings and all of these variables that
we have here are strings so we need to
parse them
into numbers
or in our clay in our case floats
so we can declare a new variable first
number and set that equal to first which
is a string
use the pass method on the string
which we can see here returns a result
and a result is similar to the option
enum in that it can be unwrapped to get
the value out
and we can do the same
for the second number
should be second dot pass
dot unwrap
now we should get a warning that russ
doesn't know what type we want the
number to be
because there are many kinds of number
in rust
we need to give it a type annotation and
we can do this in many ways
one
is to annotate the variable this way
in which case the parse method knows
to take second as a string and parse it
into an f32
or my preferred method for doing this
is to use something called turbofish
syntax which is fun to use and fun to
say
this can be done because on the pass
method you can see it accepts f
which is the type and it returns a
result of that type
so let's change second number to that as
well
now
let us declare a new function
called operate
and this will take in the operator
and we can have the operator be a car
which is the type character
we will need the first number which we
know is in f32
and the same with the second number
now we can use a bunch of if statements
to compare
if the operator is equal to the
character we expect
for example in this case
the addition character
and what we can do is return
first number plus second number
now
first thing that we'll come across is an
error
that there are mismatched types which
expected an empty tuple but found in f32
and this is because we have not added
a return type annotation to the function
we can do that with this syntax
another thing to note
is the type car
in rust
this is a character literally made using
single quotes
whereas
if we had used double quotes
that would be of the type string
let's continue with this logic
add an else if statement
comparing if operator is equal to
the minus
then we can return first number
minus second number
else
if operator
is equal to
divide by
then return first number
divided by second number
and finally the last operation we'll
need
is if
operator is equal to
an asterisk or the multiplication
operator
we will get a warning
that we don't have all of our clauses
where the if statement is missing an
else clause
this is because in rust
if the operator did not match any of
those
then the function will turn an empty
tuple and as we have typed the function
to return an f32 it cannot return an
empty tuple
so we add the base case otherwise
return for now we can just return zero
but you'll notice you cannot just type
zero
because it expects in f32 and floats
require the decimal place
something else to note about rust is it
allows implicit returns
what this means is you can get rid of
the return keyword as well as the
semicolon at the end
this is exactly the same as what we had
before
but this is the more restriction way of
writing the code
and we can do this throughout
now to use the function operate
you can declare a new variable called
result
and call the function
passing in the operator
first number
and second number
however you'll notice that we get a
warning
because operators of type string
but the function expects the type car
so we need to convert the operator into
a character
and we can do this
by using the cars method
on the string
which returns an iterator over the
characters of a string slice
and with the iterator we can call the
next method to access the first element
of that slice
and the next method returns an option
which we know we can unwrap if the value
exists
now we can print our result
let's run the code to see if this all
works as expected
and we can see one plus two the result
is equal to three
however this is not the final output we
want
and what we can do is declare a new
function called output
which will accept the first number
which we know to be an f32
the operator which is a car
the second number
which is also in f32
and then the result
which is that operation on the two
numbers which is an f32
we will want this to return a string
and in order to get the output the way
we want we can use the format macro
which is very similar to the print line
macro in that the first argument
is a reference to a string slice
which we can pass in additional
arguments which will be placed within
the curly brackets
so we want first number
operator
second number
is equal to result
and format returns a string
now to use this what we can do
is call output
and pass in first number
the operator
the second number
and the result
hopefully running the code gets us what
we expect
and that's correct one plus two is equal
to three
let's try something else
try 1 minus 2
negative 1.
however there's something much better we
can do to improve the readability of the
code and that is instead of a bunch of
else if statements
we can use rust's pattern matching
expression
which starts with match
followed by the expression to be
evaluated which in our case is the
operator
and then this is called a match on and
what this is
is if operator matches
the plus character
then evaluate the following
first number plus
second number
now because we are not including a
semicolon at the end this is implicitly
returned and we can continue with this
logic
now we will get an error
saying that we have a non-exhaustive
pattern
because similarly to the if statements
they need where we needed an else clause
the match expression
needs
a base case
which can be
represented
by the underscore
and we can still return the 0.0
and you will see that this code
runs exactly the way it did before
however
returning 0 if the operator is invalid
does not make too much sense
so
it might make more sense to panic
and you can do that using the panic
macro
and pass it a message such as
invalid operator used
now what this will do
is if an invalid operator is used
the code will panic
you can see it has panicked at invalid
operator used
but now what if we wanted to extend our
application
to not just accept multiplication
oh what's this error saying
this is an interesting case where we
need to escape the asterisk
in order to run the code
to get around that
you can extend the operate function
to not just work with an asterisk
not just match with an asterisk which
needs to be escaped each time
but it is common to multiply with an x
and we can extend it further using
between
for capital x what this allows
is instead of escaping the asterisks we
can just use x to represent
multiplication
and now this will work just fine
and that is our application finished all
that's left to do is build it
to do so you can use cargo
build to compile the binary
and you can also pass the release flag
what this does
is it provides some optimizations for
the compiler and removes all debugging
information
running this will compile our code
and the code is found
in the target directory
in the release directory
and it is called the binary's name
and we can run this code now with
arguments
oh my bad
had the period at the beginning
and then we get the same result
so that is the cli calculator finished
for the image combiner project start by
creating a new rust project using the
cargo new command
and let's call this combiner
then
cd into the combiner directory
and run the project to ensure it is set
up correctly
you should see hello world printed to
the console
this project is bigger and more complex
than the calculator project so to
prevent the main.rs file
from becoming too overwhelming
create a new file within the source
directory called augs.rs
this file will be a new module named
args which will house the logic used to
handle the command line arguments
within args.rs
create a function named getntharg
which takes a you size n
and returns a string
then we know from the previous project
that we can access the env module inside
the standard library
and call the args function
changing the nth method
to get the nth argument
and let's unwrap the value
now
to group the related command line
argument data you can create a struct
named args
you've already encountered a structs in
the previous project
this
was the string struct and the arc struct
from the env module
instead of using the nvrx struct you
will be defining a custom arc struct
specifically for use in this application
the string struct
looks something like this
where we can declare the struct
using the keyword struct
it contains
a vec field
which is a vec of u8
vek
in this case is a dynamically sized
array
so
following this syntax create a structure
named args
with three fields
image one
which is a string
image two
which is also a string
an output
to also be a string these will be the
paths
to the images
passed as arguments
within main.rs the org struct can be
imported once the aux file is declared
as a module using the mod keyword
so mod args declares the file
as a module and then we can import it
using the use keyword
you can use the aux struct by declaring
a new variable named
args in this case
and assigning it the value of the args
followed by the field name and values
for those fields
you will notice the error saying we
cannot use auxia because it is not
public
it is a private field in a private
struct
it is a private struct
to make it public
use the pub keyword before the struct
definition
now you will notice
that each of the fields
is also private
so similarly before each definition
the pub keyword
can be used to declare the field as
public
and therefore accessible
outside of the current module
as you can see here
to create a new string the new function
has been used
the reason this function can be used is
because it has specifically been
implemented for the string struct
the implementation would look something
like this
where
function u has been declared
to be implemented on the string struct
where it returns self being string
and as you can see a string is created
within it and implicitly returned
and the same goes for the new function
within the veck struct
now if you are creating many abstracts
it would be beneficial to be able to do
the same thing
that is implement a new function on the
arc struct
within
the args module
so
you can use the impul keyword
to implement new
on the struct args
when you does not take in any
arguments
in order to return self
where we can
take that code we had previously here
this time
returning it
from the new function
then
we can call args
new
to instantiate a new org
you'll notice that there is again an
error
that new is private
so before the function declaration use
the pub keyword
to make
the new function public
if we were to print out
the value of args here
you'll notice two things
the first being
that there is an error
which we've encountered before saying
that the trait displays not implemented
for args
now you may think that you could just
extend this as we have done previously
however we still get the error
where the debug trait is not implemented
for arcs
in order to implement the debugged rate
we can actually follow the compiler's
advice here
to add
this syntax
to struct definition what this does
this is an attribute it is deriving
the debug trait for the aux struct
and after doing this
we should be able to print out
the arc struct
however you'll notice that currently the
fields are all empty strings
this is not what is needed for the aux
fields so
we can replace
the string new call with
the getenthog function
passing in
1
as argument to the first chord because
the zeroth argument is the path to the
binary
continuing this logic
we can pass in
two to get the second argument
and similarly three to get the third
argument
now if we run our code
we should get an error because we are
not passing in any arguments so calling
unwrap within the getanthog function
should cause a panic
what we can do is test this by calling
our application with some arguments
and as we can see image one has
the value first image two second and
output third
for this application an external crate
called the image is required to decode
and encode the images
in much the same way other languages
have libraries or packages rust has
crates
you can add the image crate to your
application
by creating a new dependency
in the cargo.tml file
this is the name of the crate
followed by its version number in our
case 0.23
0.14
now
running cargo run
or fetch
and install
the image crate
whilst the image crate is installing
a new function
can be created within main.rs
named
find
image from path
it will take an argument path
which is a string
and we will
set the return later
the image create comes with an io module
including a reader struct
we can
create a new variable imagereader
set that equal to
the reader struct
and this struct implements an open
function which takes a path to an image
file and returns a result containing a
reader
so we can pass in the path
as the argument
and we can unwrap the result
this reader can be formatted and decoded
to yield the image format for example a
png or a jpeg
as well as the image data
a new variable
image format
will be assigned the unwrapped value
of the dot format method on the reader
the image reader being the variable
image reader
dot format
and we can unwrap the value
from within
the format
and variable image
can be assigned
and unwrapped
value of the decode method on the reader
now we are interested in both the image
and the image format variables so the
two values can be returned in a tuple
so the image as well as the image format
can be returned in a tuple
to get an idea of the types we need to
return
we can explicitly type our variables we
know this to be a reader
but the reader
has a type of a buff reader
from a file
the image format
is also a type from
the image create which is image format
and the image another type from the
image create which is a dynamic image
so we know we need to return a tuple
from this
function
and in the order it will be a dynamic
image
and an image format
then
the necessary imports can be included at
the top of the file
that is
importing from the image crate
the reader is in the i o module
and from the image create
the dynamic image
and the image format
you'll most likely get these errors
until crate has been installed
now within the main function
the return tuple can be destructured
into two new variables which we will
call it
image one
and image format one
from
find image from path
passing in
the image one
field from the arc struct
and the same can be done
for
image two
you will notice the error
about missing imports for the explicit
types within find image from path
the
buff reader and file structs need to be
imported from the standard library
the buff reader is
within the i o module
and file is within the fs module
there is an error here in the print line
statement
but for now we can get rid of that line
because we won't be using it
it is important to handle errors which
are likely to arise such as the case
where two images of different formats
are given as arguments to combine
for example
we'll need some logic
where
if image one
format is not equal to
image two format
then we'll need to return an error
a semantic way of handling such an error
is to return a result
we have encountered some results already
but a result can consist of either
an okay
or an error variant what that
practically looks like is
if we find the formats are not equal to
each other
we return an error
normally with a value within
what this means is our function needs to
be typed
to return
a result
and that result
needs to contain some values
but we also need the base case where if
there is no error our function returns
okay
it is common to see results return an
empty tuple
when there is no error
what this means is our result the type
returned on ok is an empty tuple
otherwise it will be some error the
error we will return
is
an enum and this is because enums are
useful for acting as both types and as
value for now we can call our error as
an image data error
and we will need to define this enum
to do so we use the enum keyword
followed by the name of our enum
as well as the different variants on the
enum
we have seen this
for example
with the option enum
which is defined similarly to this
where it takes sum with a value
or it just returns none
in our case we will define one of the
variants to be different
image formats
as such we can return it within
our main function an error
of image data errors
the variant
different image formats i just need to
fix
this here image format 1
image format 2.
to make combining the images easier the
largest image is resized to match the
smallest image
first
we need to find the smallest image which
we can do
using a function called get smallest
image
or get smallest dimensions i should say
because the image will consist of two
dimensions each image will have
in this case it will be a tuple
containing
the width as the u32 and the height as a
u32
and the second image we will pass in
its dimensions
which will be the same
two u32s in a tuple
what we will want to do
is return
the
smallest dimension
as a tuple
to compare the sizes we can declare
one variable variable being the number
of pixels in the first dimension
which will be
the first dimension
access the first element in that tuple
multiplying
by
the second element in the same tubule
and we can do the same
with the second tuple
now what we are comparing
is the number of pixels in the image
to do this we will
return
if
the number of pixels in the first
image is less than the number of pixels
in the second image
then we will return
the first image's dimensions
else
the second image is dimensions
we will create a function called
standardize
size
which will take in
the first image
which we know to be a dynamic
image
as well as the second image
which again is
a dynamic image
and it will return both images we can
again return them in a tuple
however these images will be resized
and what we want is
using our get smallest dimension
function we want to return the smallest
width
and the smallest height so we are
creating two new variables by
destructuring the return of get
smallest dimension
passing in
image 1
getting its dimensions by using the
dimensions method
available on the dynamic image struct
and the same with image two
except this is get smallest
dimensions
there we go
i think it is helpful
if we print out
the values of the width and height
which we can do
like so
and we can also add a new line at the
end
now what we want to do is in order to
standardize the size
we will first
find out if
for example image two
dimensions
are equal to
the width and the height
that we got from calling it's smallest
dimensions on the image then we will
know that image 2 is the smallest image
and therefore what we want to do
is we will want to resize image one
and we can use the resize
exact
method which is implemented on the
dynamic image struct
it mutably borrows the image
and using the width
height
and filter type arguments
resizes
the image so we can pass in the width
that we want
the height that we want
and now we need to pass in a filter type
this type also comes from the image
crate
and the type we will be wanting to use
is
triangle this is just used for its
simplicity
as well as
it generally does a very good job of
resizing the image without distorting it
too much
now we will need to
import triangle
it exists in
the
image ops
filter type
enum
and it is the type
triangle
there you go
now we are
wanting to return a tuple
with the resized images
so what we can do is after resizing
the first image we will then also just
return image 2 along with it in a tuple
and we will need an else clause
that is if image 1 is the smaller image
then return a 2 ball
with image 1 unchanged
resizing
image 2
passing in the new width we want the new
height
and
the filter
type you can see there are errors about
using the dimensions method
on the dynamic image
and this is because the
trait has not been brought into scope so
we can follow the compiler's advice to
get the generic imageview trade
from image
generic
image view
and that should be enough to get rid of
the errors for now fixing the typo in
the standardized
size functioning we can then
after comparing the formats
declare
image one and image two again
this time
destructured from the standardize
size function
having resized whichever image
is
the largest
now it is all well and fine that we have
we are handling resizing the images
however we know that the end goal is to
create a new image
using the pixels from
the two input images
so to handle the output a temporary
struct can be created to hold the
metadata for the output image
we can call this struct
floating image
and the metadata we will want is the
width as a u32
the height is a u32
it will contain some data
being the pixel values
as a
of u8
because the pixel values will exist
between 0 and 255 au8 perfectly fits
that number type
we also want the name of the image as a
string in order to create this floating
image
we can do as we did previously with the
arc struct and we can implement
the new function
which will take in a width
and a height
as well as the name
and it will return
a new floating image
and what this will look like
is floating image with a value of the
input width and height
we know that there will be some sort of
data
as well as
the name
now for the data
when we create the new floating we won't
have the pixel values yet but we will
need to reserve the space for them in
memory in order to do this
we can declare a buffer
and that buffer could be a fixed value
such as
let's say
buffer capacity
set this to some number
for example
three million six hundred and fifty five
thousand seven hundred and forty four
and then the buffer itself
will
be a vector
with the capacity
of that buffer capacity
and then we can assign the buffer to
this data
an interesting thing about rust
is that you can use
this number format to make
your numbers easier to read
where you separate three digits of your
number using an underscore however what
we have here assumes that any image we
input will not be larger than
essentially this number of bytes but we
can more dynamically size this
based on the fact that we know that our
image will consist of a height
we can multiply that by the width
and to get the number of pixels we
multiply this by four
the reason for this will be clearer as
we go through this next where we will be
using rgba values
so we are multiplying by four because
there we are using the red the green the
blue and the alpha values for each pixel
you will see we have a warning here
that there are mismatched types with
capacity function expected to use size
but founder u32 the reason buff capacity
is of type u32 is because we used the
height and the width to create it which
are u32s
normally
rust would automatically invert or try
to convert
the number type into the correct type
however in this case we cannot be
certain that this is possible
so
we can follow the advice the compiler is
giving
to try to convert the value
otherwise if that's not possible
fail
or in this case panic
so we can try into
and then unwrap
however in order to use the try into
method
we need to bring it into scope and it
exists
in the standard library in the convert
module of the tray into implementation
so we can just bring that
into
scope now within main we can create
an output variable
containing
the new floating image
we will use image ones
width
and image one's height
as the inputs
for the new function
we could use image two as well
but
considering image one and image two have
been resized to be the same size the
width and height will be identical
anyway
and we will want to pass in the output
field from the arc struct
as this will be the name
of the function and the location which
we will later use
at this point we can deal with the error
that we have up here which is saying
that the trade debug is not implemented
for image data errors
we can resolve this
by following a compiler's advice to use
the attribute and derive the debug trait
for our image data errors enum
the reason this is necessary is because
main returns to the standard output the
result of running the code normally
either being a status of one or zero
and in order to return to the standard
output the debug trait
needs to be derived
from here we can run our code to see if
everything is working as expected
what we will need
are two images as inputs to get these
images
i'll just be importing them
into our combiner project
within the images folder we have three
images here
first being
my profile picture
the other being the free code camp logo
and the other an inverted free code camp
logo that we might use later
then in order to test
our code
we can go
cargo run
passing in the arguments which we know
to be
images folder
we can pass in my
profile image
as well as the image to the free code
camp cliff
both of these images are pngs
we also need to specify an output
location
which we can say is within images
and
we can set it to test our png
we have not currently implemented
anything for the output image to go into
however we still need to provide the
argument
get a few warnings
the code panic because i called
the wrong folder name here
running again we can see that the width
and the height are output
so everything is working as expected
as i said earlier
in order to process the images they are
converted into a vector of rgba pixels
and pixels are stored as u8 because
their values are between 0 and 255.
so in order to process our images we'll
be creating a new function
called combine images
and this will take an image one which we
know to be a dynamic image
image two
the same
and this will return our equivalents
the dynamic image struct implements the
two rgba8 method which returns an image
buffer
containing a vector u8 and the image
buffer implements the intuvec method
which returns the back itself
so to visualize that a bit better let's
declare a new variable called vect1
which will be image1
we will call the
2rgba
8 method on the dynamic image
you'll notice that it returns an image
buffer containing
an rgb u8 as well as the vector u8
so in order to get the box out
we can call
the into back method
on the image buffer
likewise we can do for
vec 2 and image 2
in processing our images we will want to
alternate the pixels of the two images
so what we'll do is we will create a
function
called
alternate pixels
and what this will do it will take in
the two vectors
and it will return a vector of uh for us
so let's define that function
we know that it takes in
two thick
or v8
and it also returns a vector viewed
first we need to declare a variable
which i will call combined data
that will hold the data of the two
images after they have been alternated
in essence we'll be pushing the pixels
from one vector and then pushing the
pixels from the next vector
and in order to size the combined data
we will match it
using a back macro we want
e weights
and we want the number of u8 to be the
same
length
as
any of the vectors passing in this case
they are the same but we will just set
them
to be the size of the first vector what
this vec macro does it will create for
example
if
vec one dot length
is equal to 100 or
no let's say five
then
the vac macro
will create a vector
of u8
of that same length
now what else we will do is we will use
a while loop
to go over each pixel
in this case we will refer to the pixels
as indices within
the length of the vector
and first we will need to declare this i
variable
and we will know that we'll want to
mutate our variable so we'll declare it
as a mutable
variable
starting at zero
and within the while loop we will
increment
by four
this is done because we are using rgba
sets within the vector
and being four values we need to
increment i by four as we're actually
accessing the indices within the vector
using the modulo operator
we can say that
if i modular eight
is equal to zero
we will
splice intercombined data
the rgba set from vec1
in order to do this
we need to set the range in our case the
range will be from i
until i
plus 3 and we will need to get
the rgba set from the first vector
to do this we will create a little
function
set our
gpa
what this will do it will take in the
first vector it will take in a starting
index as well as
an ending index
and it will return the rgba set from
those indices
otherwise
we will want to do similarly
this time
passing in vec2
so
let's define that set rgba function
we know that it takes in a vector
this spec will be
a vac of uh
do i have a starting index which is you
size
as well as
an end index also a u size
and we will want to return the evacuate
set
in order to do this we will be declaring
a mutable vector
rgba
it's just a new vector
and
for every
index
in
the start
until the end inclusive
we will declare
a new variable
val
we'll set this equal to
vec.get and pass in the index that we
are interested in
then
after doing that we will push that index
to
the rgba
vector
we'll push that value
and then we will want to return
that vector
we have an issue here with get returns
an option
what we could do is just unwrap to get
the value
however
there
is a chance
that that value doesn't exist so what
would actually be better
is for us to match
on get call
and if there is some value
it's called that value d
what we want to do is
return the value
and if there is none
what we want to do is potentially panic
and say that the
index is out of bounds
now you will notice that we get an error
up here saying that the function
expected to return a vector v8s but
instead is returning an empty tuple
to resolve that we can
return the combined data
you'll notice we have an issue here
where
combined data is being spliced so what
we actually need to do is declare it as
mutable
and we get an error down here saying
that it's expected
the function is expected to return if it
could be rates however it is actually
returning a vec
of u8 but the u8s are referenced
what this means is we are pushing
reference values
in this case currently val
is equal to
the reference v8
what we want is for it to be just u8 in
order to do that we can use the
asterisks
before
the variable what this does is
dereference the value
that resolves the error
however
now we have a new error saying
that the borrow of a moved value vac one
where the value borrowed after being
moved
here we can see that vec one
has been moved
why this is is because within the while
loop we are passing vac one into the set
rgba function we don't actually want to
pass in the whole value what we want to
do is we want to pass in a reference
to a value a pointer
and the same needs to be done
with back two
now we need to adjust the function
definition as it's not accepting vec
u8 accepting a reference to a backup v8
to clarify
the syntax here
is rust's range syntax which allows the
range to be inclusive of the end value
so far we haven't called these functions
yet
however what we need to do first is to
set the data of bind data into the
output image
which we actually need to call output
a method on floating image
needs to be defined to set the data
field of the output to the value of that
combined data because currently what we
have for the data field is just a buffer
not the actual pixel values we are
interested in
so far you have only defined functions
on structs
however
now we are wanting to define a method
methods are defined in a similar way but
they take an instance of the struct as
their first argument
you saw this with the next method
so
we are going to define
a method called set data
on the floating image what this will do
is it will take a mutable reference to
self as well as the data we are wanting
to set which is
effectively rates
what this will do
is return a result
either on ok or turn an empty tube or it
want to return one of our
image.error
enum variants
what we can do
is first make sure
that data.len
is greater than
the
current floating images
capacity
if the length
of the data is more than the capacity
of the current floating image what this
means is we cannot store
we did not reserve enough buffer
in order to store that data so
here we will return an error and this
type of error will be
an image data errors
and we'll need to declare a new variant
and this will be buffer too small
so we need to define that variant
to buffer two small
otherwise
we can just
set the data to the data that is passed
into the method
in that case
the result is okay
now within main we can call that method
on output
passing in the combined data
you'll notice that again only one
argument is passed into set data because
implicitly
the first argument of a method is
self
we need to define combined data
let's do that first and say let combine
data
equal to we have the combine
images function
and it takes in
image one and image two and what we've
done
is we've made it that set data
returns a result
an interesting thing you can do with
rust is propagate that result value by
adding a question mark at the end of the
expression
what this will do is essentially unwrap
the value but it propagates it into the
current function and as main already
returns a result
of either okay with an empty tuple
or an error with image data areas which
is the same
function signature as set data we can
use error propagation operator finally
the new image needs to be saved to a
file the image create has a save buffer
with format function which works like
this
we can use save
buffer
with format
we need to pass in the path
of where we want to save the image
which we have stored in the name field
of output
we need to pass in the data from output
however this needs to be
a reference to the data and not
passing the value itself
and he's passing the width
of the new image
and the height of the image
we need to define the color type of the
image
where we can get the color type from the
image crate
and we know that the type is rgba
and they are u8 and finally the format
of the image
which will be the same
as
image one format this function also
returns a result so we can unwrap that
and i need to
remember
to correctly name my variables
you'll see we still get an error about
output
where we cannot borrow it as mutable
because it's not declared immutable this
is because inset data
as a method it takes a mutable reference
to self
which in this case is output so we need
to declare our output variable has been
mutable
to test out our image combiner
we can once again
call cargo run
and pass in the arguments which we know
to be images
to
my profile png
images
to the fcc glyph
and we'll output this image into the
images folder and we will call it
output.png
running this will compile the code
and once it has finished
we should be able to navigate into that
images
folder
and find the output
and there it is
the profile image
and the free code can glove combined
into one image
although the application is finished we
have a lot of calls to unwrap within our
code
what this means is if at any point there
is an error during runtime our code will
panic
and it may not provide the best user
experience or the best area to help a
developer debug as they are using the
application
so one thing we can do to extend this as
we already have some basic error
handling within our main function where
we are returning result
where if there are any errors we are
returning image data areas
which is our enum
we can extend this further with some
more common types of error
so for example fixing up the find image
from path function
instead of unwrapping on the reader open
returns a result
so what we can do
is
we can match
on the result
and if this expression is okay
we will get the image reader
otherwise
if there is an error we can get this
error out in a variable named e
and then we can return
an image data error
and we will add a new type of unable
to read
image from path
as a variant on our image data areas
enum and we can pass an e
as a value to the enum
so let us define this new variant
we named it unable to read image from
path
and we know it takes in some sort of
error
now
this error exists in the standard
library
as standardio
error
next
we need to move our logic
within this match arm
but we can continue
with the next unwrap statement however
format returns an option
and the general rule of thumb i follow
with how to handle options versus
results is as we have already done with
a result we match on the result and we
handle the okay variant versus the error
variant however if we are dealing with
an option
what i like to do
is use an if let statement
and that looks something like this
if let
there is a value that is the option
returns sum
then
we can declare a new variable
called image format
and if this is the case we can perform
some logic
else
we can return an error
in this case you'll need to explicitly
return error
image data errors
and we will declare a new variant called
unable to format
image
and something we can do here is pass in
the path
that way our area has more information
with it as to which image it failed to
read
now we cannot pass in path as is because
we are moving it into this
open call so what we need to do is pass
in a reference to the path
to the first open call and then we can
define that variant
and we call that variable unable
to format image
and it took in a string
then handling the image logic
as decode
returns a result we can
match on the result
match on the result
and in the arms
if okay
we can get the value in a variable
called image
and we can return okay
with the tuple that we expect being
image as well as the image format
otherwise if there is an error
we can get the error in a variable
called e
and return that error in
again another variant of image data
errors enum
and this variant we will call unable to
decode image
and we will pass in
that area as is
so to declare this new variant which we
named unable to decode image it takes in
a specific error from the image crate
which is called image error
as such we need to add it to our
dependency
then we can remove some of this logic
that we are no longer using and we need
to fix up some things so we need to
define
our function to return a result
and on this result it is either
returning tuple which we originally had
otherwise it we know it is returning one
of the
image data errors variants
then as we learned earlier earlier
we can propagate the errors
into the main function
as we are calling it using the error
propagation operator
and finally we have one more unwrap to
deal with and this is on the safe buffer
with format function
now what we can do with this is as it is
returning a result however we are only
actually interested in the case where
there is an error we will again use an
if let
expression
destructuring the error from the call
this way
we can just return the error if there is
one
in a new variant called unable to save
image
and pass in that error
otherwise we can
return okay
to define
that variant which we named unable
to save image
and we are passing in
again an image error from the image
crate
we've also rejigged this to no longer be
using these imports
so what we can do
is just remove that
and just like that we are handling our
errors in a much better way to inform
both the developer and or the final user
of what is happening when any of these
areas arise